this is a real turning point where this
technology is used by a service that
reaches a billion people this has never
happened
what's at can't read those messages the
government can't read those messages
even if it comes to whatsapp with the
wiretap because whatsapp can't comply
with the wiretap the basic idea is is
that if I have a phone I have what's
called a private key on this on this
device
elsewhere on a server let's say it's
whatsapp server there's what's called a
public key and that public key is used
to sin send me a message once that
message reaches me the only way to
decrypt it is through the private key so
if you don't have both you cannot
decrypt the message what's that server
does not have both it only has the
public key and so if a government for
instance goes to whatsapp and says I
want to read the message that was sent
to me
whatsapp cannot comply some governments
have called for what's called a backdoor
in an encryption like this if you open a
back door in your encryption system how
do you control who gets access to the
back door you immediately open up a hole
in your system it almost defeats the
purpose of the system but the other big
question is is can you completely trust
your government but on the other hand
you do want to protect your citizens and
their privacy and in that sense this
encryption and this is one big reason
why whatsapp is doing this it provides
that personal protection to individual
privacy